I'm 31 years old and I have about a 210
000 net worth but back in 2018 I had a
negative 70 000 net worth
[Music]
hi I'm Chloe bear Financial coach and
Creator I was able to take my
investments from ten thousand dollars to
over a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars in less than two years here's
what you gotta do very first thing get
your 401k or 403b match it's one of the
easiest ways to get started with
investing make sure you pick Investments
though so my favorite are index funds
but it depends on what your employer
offers you inside of the 401K then
you're going to open a Roth IRA or a
traditional IRA why because we want to
use tax advantaged accounts you can do
this by picking a brokerage I like
Fidelity and Vanguard you then transfer
money over into the account and then
when that money becomes available you
pick investment don't forget that part
you need to pick investment again I like
index funds either ETFs or mutual funds
and then make sure you're doing this
monthly